in seven months a Las Vegas strip will
Echo with the sounds of formula one but
bringing the Grand Prix racing here to
the core of the valley is a major
challenge it's not the first time Las
Vegas streets have been turned into a
race track though 16 years ago this
weekend downtown had its big speed show
the corner of Maine and Bonneville speed
limit around 30 miles an hour
so it was a little more this was part of
2007's Vegas Grand Prix circuit the old
champ car series came to town a nearly
two mile race track snaked through
downtown Las Vegas we're having fun you
know it's like I see another cake this
is great one of the driving forces
behind the race Dale Jensen what we're
doing is we're throwing a big party and
we just happen to have a race that
breaks out the Phoenix businessman has a
slightly different take on the race
today the bad side was what it cost me I
mean it that was expensive at the time
champ Carr was one of the top racing
series in the country Paul Tracy was one
of its top drivers the Canadian also
called Las Vegas home at the time kind
of the start of revitalizing the
downtown all the potential was there it
just didn't didn't last back in 2007
Jorge Cervantes was Deputy Public Works
director we've been having almost weekly
meetings with a lot of property owners
today he's the city manager it was a big
effort uh we hadn't really closed down
that Porsche version of downtown before
we did a lot of planning a lot of there
for a lot of people that pulled this off
early on Jensen had setbacks what sales
do we have everybody was kind of well we
haven't got them yet as race weekend
started there were 40 000 or so fans
more watched for free along the streets
[Music]
were a problem road crews had to cut
down the crown in the road along Ogden
race cars were taking flight the track
was really actually a really nice Street
course while competitors enjoyed the
track layout the public complained about
getting around the closures how do you
keep uh businesses going and how do you
keep people circulating while all this
being set up the race was supposed to
come back for two more years except
after the problems we faced getting the
sponsorship and those type of things for
the race I just didn't have the stomach
to go try it again
Jensen lost a lot of the six million
dollars he put in then the champ car
series went away after the season had it
all together Vegas Grand Prix was one
and done a shame really because you know
I think it you know it had great
potential by the way we got Hamilton
gets away this November the much bigger
Formula One Circus Comes To Town it's a
chance for Las Vegas to give street
racing another high-profile try they
said that's going to be the first time
they've ever had a race on the strip and
I was like wait a minute we did we did
have a race on strip it was successful
in that it was a good race I ended up
losing but whatever
foreign